ok let's get into audience questions for
the week first question today hey David
could the United States ever actually
become a truly socialist or communist
country this is a hard question to even
dig into because it depends on what you
mean with those terms ok so first of all
there aren't really 100% unanimously
agreed upon definitions of those systems
but we can sort of think about it in the
following way
socialism is a system where workers own
the means of production so you don't
have private ownership of businesses and
in many cases you don't have private
ownership of property although sometimes
you can have the private property but
you don't have the private businesses
where all employees own the businesses
but individuals can still own private
property you have other situations where
the government owns all the companies
but that sometimes is called communism
if it's still a profit-driven market
economy but the government owns all the
companies that's not really communism
that's more actually state capitalism
then you get to when the government owns
the means of production in a non
free-market economy private property is
often also eliminated altogether that's
the closest to the style of the Marxist
Leninist or Stalinist Leninist
ideal and that is sort of like a working
definition of what communism might be
but the key question here is could this
happen in the United States I believe
that full-on socialism and full-on
capitalism are not going to happen in
the United States if ever for a very
very long time and the reason I say that
is right now first of all the United
States is not a fully capitalist country
to begin with right the US has never
been a totally capitalist system to
begin with a real lazy fair system as it
would be called government has been
intertwined with the economy subsidies
taxes education Medicare the postal
service contracts for private companies
from the government there's this endless
list where this has never actually been
a true lays affair totally capitalist
market driven system and in that same
sense the idea that we would ever fully
become a socialist or communist nation
is unlikely from a merely structural
perspective because most countries in
the world are not uniquely just one
system they're sort of blends in some
ways the other reason why at least
anytime in the near future
total socialism or total communism isn't
likely in the United States is that
there's no major socialist or communist
party in the United States yes over the
last ten years we've seen the word
socialism have fewer and fewer negative
connotations compared to where it was
coming out of the Cold War for example
but the most far left Democrats are
basically Social Democrats there's a
handful of actual Democratic socialists
many call themselves Democratic
Socialist without actually being
socialists so there's not even a
significant clamoring for socialism in
the United States if you believe Marxist
theory then you could conceive of the
idea that there will eventually be a
sort of uprising of the proletariat
against the bourgeoisie and that you
will have a Marxist uh pending of our
system but short of believing that Marx
will be fulfilled to the letter at some
point in the future we are more than
likely going to continue indefinitely
having a mixed system a system that has
elements of capitalism and social
democracy and even maybe some elements
of democratic socialism but to truly get
to one of those systems you would need
one a a real desire for that or if the
idea is a dictator will appear from
above and impose that you would need to
first eliminate a lot of the sort of
constitutional and democratic safeguards
that exist which would allow such a
system to come to power so I don't see
it as I've said before I believe that
the best
are mixed full-fledged capitalism is a
disaster Stalinist Leninism is a
disaster authoritarian police states are
bad I believe that very well regulated
capitalism with a significant floor so
that people don't fall below and
significant spending on socially
democratic programs is the way forward